joining us right here on the phone line
is somebody who's going to have a pretty
big monday night football game coming up
his team has beaten uh the bucks and the
carolina panthers in back to back weeks
the washington football team is on a
roll and joining us on the mercedes-benz
van phone line is one of our favorites
the hc of the wft ron rivera here on the
rich eisen show how you doing coach i'm
doing great rich how are you i'm doing
fine uh there's so many different ways
to start uh with you uh first things
first is how's your health how's
everything going it's good it's been
going very well you know i don't know if
you know but i celebrated my my one year
ringing the bell and i also had my one
year biopsy that was a negative so
that's all good news so far that is
amazing that is so great that is
terrific and um glad to hear that what a
great thanksgiving week for you then huh
for you and your family really is and
and i just want to share this with with
you very quickly um you know our my
players took a collection in honor of
that for me and they wanted to donate
and
26
nine dollars to the red frog proton
therapy center at st jude's on on behalf
of the run rich run program that is so
amazing oh my gosh uh wow um
thank you very much and so the team got
together and so explain what the the red
frog events proton therapy center is at
st jude well what it is proton therapy
is a very specific and precise uh
treatment that that that is real
important to children because you know
when you get photon therapy for
radiation treatment it's a very broad
beam and it creates a little it causes
some collateral damage whereas if you
get proton therapy it's a very direct
beam that limits the amount of
collateral damage which is very
important for children's health and so
it's something that that's saint jude's
and it benefits the children um greatly
when they have to go through uh
radiation treatment
so generous man and it must feel so
great to have a team that's like you
know what let's celebrate our coaches
one year being cancer-free let's raise
some money for for kids that is
beautiful that's good it was really cool
rich that is beautiful and so who what's
with the 59 uh is it somebody
that just happened to be happenstance
from what i understand but if not i
really do appreciate the gesture that
they made
i love it i love it well done ron rivera
here on the rich eisen show uh how weird
was it for you to go back into carolina
with another team
it was very weird in fact you know
i got a little mixed up and it wasn't
for my chief of staff telling me i'm
headed to the wrong bench i would have
stood there for a second come on did you
really do that did you really do that i
did i did when i first came out for
warm-ups you know i i always you know
kind of lifted lazily to the right and
that's where i was headed and you know
thank goodness you came up with the
coach you're headed to the wrong bench
could it have been that you also saw a
cam in a panthers uniform that also
confused you could it be that too
that did confuse me a little bit to be
honest with you i i saw the big guy
coming out oh and i had a little
flashback to the good old days no and
again i know that that's this is another
team but you you you you did have to
sense and you knew you knew it had to be
coming what energy he sends through that
building oh and that time oh my god it
was unbelievable it was it was truly
energetic and you can see it also
inspiring his teammates i mean you know
and i've told some people hey you guys
got to be aware now this dude he learns
a little bit more and gets more
comfortable what they're doing they got
a chance because i love the defense i
love their playmakers they've got some
good football players absolutely and
then him spiking the ball in the middle
of the field too i know you don't want
that that was at your expense but uh
that was uh that was a long time coming
for him i imagine
you know it was it wasn't and you know
the beautiful thing about about what he
does more so than anything else is he
really does play with a lot of energy
ron rivera here on the rich eisen show
let's talk about your team what's
happened over the last two weeks do you
think
well i think it was actually uh uh in in
it it began i think a few weeks prior to
that i really do i thought our guys
played well against green bay i thought
they played well against tampa bay we
had our moments we didn't we didn't
complete the game so we didn't finish uh
with an opportunity to win
but going into dubai really liked our
our attitude the way we went into it as
coaches we got an opportunity to really
study and do do a lot of self scouting
and we came back and we basically told
the guys these are what we're seeing
these things that we got to work on
these are things that we've got to get
better at let's go and do that and we
had a really good week of preparation
going into tampa bay
um and we felt really confident they
played with confidence they played fast
and and we were
were i think had a good week last week
where we were building off of that uh
off of that success
so um
has heineken has aligned like gone on a
little bit more with him i know you were
constantly pounding him about protecting
the football and not making that 90
point play that he thought he could try
and make right so yep is that part of
this equation too i think i think it is
because you know one thing that that we
talked about going into the year was
that you know we needed a quarterback
that could manage the offense control
the pace and tempo but had the ability
to make plays when we needed them and
that's what we're getting from taylor i
mean he's been very smart very judicious
with handling the ball i mean you know
like i said a few weeks back
we were great between the 20s but we
struggled in the red zone um we go into
the buy we get a few players back you
know we got a couple of our uh wide
receivers back that had gotten hurt and
that we had missed for a few weeks we
got a couple of our offensive lineman
back and you could see with the way they
were playing that there was some
confidence and and taylor's playing with
confidence right now because again let's
not forget this is only he's only had 11
starts in the nfl
right so what's the goal here um is the
division still in sight do you think
here oh absolutely i mean i'm going to
look at it that way because if we put
ourselves in position and and we're
fortunate enough to get through
this part of november and get to the
second week of the december in the right
situation set of circumstances the
division why not we play five straight
divisional games and there's you know i
i'm one of those who believe in that
saying that if you're going to win the
division you've got to control the
division so we'll see what happens but
we're going to take them one at a time
we got a big monday night showdown
coming up with seattle and we're pretty
excited about the opportunity to just
get back on the football field and play
again you know they're going to be
desperate too i mean pete carroll i
don't know if you saw pete left his
press conference at one point because
you know and he said that he thought
that the time was up and he went back
and he finished the press conference but
you could see he's four games under 500
for only the second time in the middle
of a season for the first time in his
career you know so you know you know
this is it for that oh yeah in many ways
but you know i mean he's a veteran coach
and he he knows how to handle it he'll
bounce back and he'll get his guys
focused and you know that's what we got
to be ready for we got ready for a
football team that's got an opportunity
just like we do you know if they handle
their business so that's why i really
believe this is going to be a good game
yeah and the challenge with russ is what
oh absolutely absolutely but dude you
know the dude's one of the league
quarterbacks in this league what's the
challenge like what do you got to do
here
first of all i gotta contain him keep
him inside the pocket um and then get
him off his mark but you can't let him
get outside of that i mean if he gets
off his mark it's got to be going
backwards he can't be going sideways and
stepping up because you know he's got
great vision he knows where his guys are
his guys know when certain situations
happen where they need to be and he'll
find them so we've got to be able to
contain it um they got a good running
game we've got to be able to keep that
running game in check as well so this
this is this game will challenge us for
sure a few more minutes left here with
ron rivera the head coach of the
washington football team uh you're
joining me just about 20 minutes after
news breaking out of new york city that
the giants have let jason garrett go as
the offensive coordinator again i know
that's not your team i know it's a team
in division i'm sure you know jason
garrett very well yeah well as a what
does an hc of one team think when the
other team bounces in oc like what goes
to your head i think when coaches get
let go you know the first thought is
okay they're trying to find you know
spark they're trying to do something
different and create um you know a
little momentum going somewhere um and
that's probably what they're trying to
do and and again it's hard to say
because you know there's so many things
going on but uh you know that's kind of
the way i always look at it when
something like that happens right i mean
but how much is scheme i guess can can
change right i mean how much can you
change in the middle of a season i don't
mean to turn you into an analyst here oh
well oh yeah you know you're an expert
on the subject matter i imagine so how
much yeah but but what will happen is
you'll have a guy that has a different
way of calling it you know different way
of seeing it and and game planning might
be different that's probably the biggest
thing okay and another thing is what are
you making of the uh the
emphasis on the taunting rule uh you
being a head coach in this league i
think we kind of hit hit it on it
earlier this year and i i totally
understand about
um
you know uh wanting to get the screaming
at one player standing over another
player out of the game but sean payton
who is on the competition committee says
it's now being over officiated where do
you stand on it right now yeah coach i i
i you know and i don't disagree with
with with with sean because you know
again the point of emphasis being is
that we don't want it to be one of those
things where there's some backlash and i
think at that point there has to be some
judgment um as far as the referees are
concerned i know we're putting a little
something extra on them again but you
know you really got to be smart about we
have to be careful because we hate to
see it really costs an opportunity
especially with the playoffs now right
around the corner or even during the
playoffs but we've got to make sure the
referees have a true definition of what
they really are looking for so what do
you what do you think do you think uh
what did you think a couple weeks ago
with the cassius marsh call where he was
staring at a bench and he got 15 percent
oh that's tough i mean he could have
turned around stared at his bench and
and did what he did you know what i'm
saying i mean that's the whole point
because you know we had a situation you
know in in denver where where a guy
raised the ball after you know pretty
much a interception in the fourth
quarter that was that was really close
to sealing the deal
you know
it was right in front of our bench and
you got to be careful somebody might
retaliate just you that's what you're
that to me is what you're trying to
prevent
that stuff if you want to celebrate
celebrate with your teammates go to your
bench go to the end zones
right just you know be aware and and you
know and to a degree be humble and
respectful to your opponent well i mean
and technically though coach what cam
did running to the center of his field
and spiking the ball in the middle
it it i totally understood what he was
doing i was oh yeah i totally understood
what he was doing right he's like he's
back he's like making his mark right and
and obviously
he didn't do it in your direction he did
it on his own logo if he was on your
field and he did it on your logo that
might be something that's provocative
you know t.o back in the day with the
star but i was legitimately concerned
that he was going to get flagged for it
and i'm like man what a waste of my
viewing experience that feeling is and i
i i kind of blame the situation yeah you
know what i mean i don't disagree with
you i really don't i mean again you know
i'm one i'm on the competition committee
and that's one of the things that we
discussed okay you know we what we
wanted to prevent where the retaliatory
fights that's what we're trying to we're
really trying to say you know getting in
that guy's face um
going to their bench stepping towards
that guy stepping over a guy you know
doing things like that that's what we're
really looking for you know if a guy
gets up and he yells and he and he drops
the ball and just happens to be right in
front of a guy you know without the
intent of being in on that you know
doing it to that guy i get that and i
appreciate that as a former player i
appreciate the excitement and exuberance
but this is one of the things we tell
our guys
and we've got flag twice this year but
we've told our guys
don't do something that's going to make
the referee think okay don't put it on
them don't give them an opportunity and
and we've done it twice so i struggle
with that but you know again we've told
the guys not to so when you go back in
next march do you think there's going to
be another conversation here oh i
believe there will be and there should
be because again we if we're going to
have the rule we got to make sure we get
the rule right
okay and if we can't get it right then
maybe we don't need to have the rule
uh okay before i let you go uh do you
know right now as you and i are talking
ron rivera what your football team is
going to be called in 2022 do you know
that right now um
i have an idea i i know that there are
three finalists and uh i know we're
getting ready to order everything and
you know when they get ready to do all
that we'll know for sure well when they
make an order i mean that thing's locked
right oh yeah yeah once once it's all
set in stone and you know they've
they've called up the
the uh the uh the manufacturers that
said okay hey we need to get these and
then we'll know for sure so yeah right
so the washington eisens we got that yes
no
you can i'm i'm i'm pulling for the
golden retrievers oh
now that would be the winner
that would be the winner i like that one
you could say go get them you know go
get the ball that's for sure okay all
right but you do know it's down to three
and do you know when the order is going
to be placed you got something uh very
shortly i i know it's coming i really do
okay all right ron i'm just trying to
get something take care of yourself and
by the way so generous i've never in my
run
had money in the till before the end of
the year uh before you know the end of
the year uh like this for the next
year's run i've never had that so you've
literally given me a head start and i
can't take you enough you're so good
yourself that was awesome it was awesome
of our players and again just to a very
worthy cause i mean st jude's for what
they do for children and families is an
amazing thing well and again just the
fact that you think of looping me in
when you know clearly your name it says
in honor of coach rivera and the memo of
the check that we're seeing right here
um thank you you're you're very kind to
include and loop me into this thank you
very much
appreciate you rich thank you right back
at you that's ron rivera riverboat run
hc on twitter
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here